they ask says he was injured three years
ago in a chemical bombing
but has refused asylum outside syria
which is he says
his home but that home is now
a displaced person's camp in northern
idlib province
where feyers earns what little he can
repairing shoes
he lives with eight members of his
family in one tent
and says there are 50 families squeezed
into just 30 tenths in the camp
in 2018 fez was guarding empty houses
with other anti-government rebels a few
kilometers
south in syracuse when the syrian regime
launched an attack
a helicopter was in the sky and we knew
that we have to resort to the shelters
because normally it would drop a barrel
bomb but that evening there was no
explosion
so one guy opened the shelter's door and
we were suddenly struck by the smell of
chlorine
we went outside to find a lot of people
struggling and in pain with the gas
in its headquarters at the hague on
wednesday the global chemical watchdog
the opcw
balloted in favor of stripping syria of
its voting rights
87 countries supported the sanction 15
were against
including russia china and iran it sends
a clear
political message and
syria will no longer be able to take
part in
in any voting unless it has redressed
satisfactorily uh the issues at hand
so the practical implications are not
massive but it is a significant
political signal
an investigation by the opcw blamed
damascus for three
poison gas attacks in the village of
latimina in march
2017. it said syrian planes and
helicopters
dropped chemical bombs there over three
days
four years previous to that the syrian
government agreed to join the opcw
after a suspected sarin nerve gas attack
killed 1400 people
it promised to give up all chemical
weapons
but the investigation found otherwise
and testimonies such as those of fears
khattabs
would suggest the regime even after
latamina
continues gas attacks against its
population
viaz refuses to leave syria as a refugee
saying he wants to see justice in his
own land
laura berdimanli al jazeera